バンキラジオ
[音楽]
や俺の名前は天才小学生やす最近は野球に
はまっているったやったやっ
たお母さん俺ここに入って焼き始めたい
だめですバットもグローブもお金がかかる
でしょへえ
あああ
[音楽]
お
よしできたなんだっ
てはいキャッチボール練習
はいはい
はい
はい行く
よ体操せーの
1212明日はアムカ球団との試合です
みんな頑張りましょうはい
[拍手]
よろしくお願いします
よしなんか怖いねレイよろしくお願いし
[音楽]
ます
スクななんて速さ
だスク
ストリークストリークウわストリーク
バットアウトチェンジ
よし
[音楽]
おりゃれオ俺俺俺
俺くやたた
コールドゲーム相が球団の
勝利くそ強すぎるんよ強いなそしたら
仲良くなって教えてもらおうか
なみんな友達になってほしいなプリン
パクパクプリンパクパクプリンパクパク
おいしいプリンパクパクプリンパクパク
プリンパクパク
おいしい雑魚がてなめてんのかおら
うわう
雑魚どもなんだあのへっぴり腰の
バッティングはよ情け
ねえいくらなんでもそんな言い方はないよ
野球は強いやつが正義だなめた雑魚どもは
野球やめて帰ってゲームでもやってろあ
来月の試合だったっけかかわいそうにママ
に慰めてもらえなちち
[音楽]
悔しい悔しいこうなったら絶対勝って
やれはいじゃあ今日も頑張りましょう
監督僕を監督にさせてくださいえ楽しむ
野球ではなくかつ野球をしたいんです本気
でやるために勉強してきました
そこまで言うなら仕方ないす君頑張ってみ
なさいありがとうございますみんな聞いて
くれあも球団で次に試合をするのは1か月
後そこで必ず勝てるメニューを組んでき
たさあ練習
[音楽]
[拍手]
だその後俺たちは過酷なトレーニングを
続けた
[音楽]
そして敵チームのことも徹底的に調べ上げ
たおい雑魚じゃねえ
か負たのか
またこれからバンカラ球団とアイモ球団の
試合を始めます生々堂々と戦うように高い
にねよろしくお願いし
[音楽]
ますポール
え作戦通り
おル
[音楽]
パワーは強いが今までの練習の力で
打ち返すんだ
[音楽]
や
タイムあの技を使う
か田これを食え
お必殺技
[音楽]
だなんてパワー
だ交代
スこのスピードなら問題ねえ
[音楽]
なそう実はボールトグローブに磁石を
押し込みあいつらの苦手なコースに弾を操
したの
さ何してんすかが打てます
よこいつは苦手なインコースであえて
打ち上げ
[音楽]
させるゆうと10時の方向に15歩全力
出して了
1015何してるかしら知らねが俺は
どんな弾でも撃てる
ぞ順に苦手な吸収がないのは想定済みだが
これはどうだ必殺技ミッシング
ボールなんだ弾が消えた
[音楽]
ぞ勝たアウト交代
タドもうあれは絶望なんよこじりひたすら
たにファール当て続けろ
いやーフール
やーポール
やー
ポール
タイムエネルギー切れだあれだせ
[音楽]
はいよし行く
ぞく計画通り
あいつのエネルギー源であるバナナを
うまい棒にすり替えておいたのさこれで
あいつはもう力を出せ
ない
や
[音楽]
やさらにデッドボール作戦
だデッド
ボール計画通り
よいしょおバッティングからデッドボール
受けられるようにしろえ僕は野球がしたい
よお願い30円あげるからやった30円も
くれんのありがとうこれで新品のキっが
よものおかで痛くないよその後も
ストライクゾーン狭作戦などにより確実に
点数を取っていった
[音楽]
くそどうなってんだら負けは許さない
どんな手でも
使えあいつピッチャーもできたの
[音楽]
かまあいいどうせ撃てる
だろ早すぎる
スったアウト甲子
交代あちょっといいこっちのボールの方が
綺麗だから使っ
[音楽]
てやっぱりボールすりかしたのか生々堂々
戦い
やあ
[音楽]
キキキ痛いだろやあ痛い
よずるいよあ審判が見てなかったら関係
ねえんだよほらこのハもポイしまえば見え
ない審判に言いつけてやるおい行ったら
どうなるか分かってんだろうな
くそその後も次々に点数を取られさ
ミッシング
ボールあれ
[音楽]
だミッシングボールの煙の装置も破壊さ
れああれドローンも破壊さ
れ
くそ交代気づけば点差をつけられていた
[音楽]
くそ強
すぎるもう無理だ
よ
スタウト諦めない絶対に勝つん
だ俺が開発したこのマになるぜ君それは体
に負担がかかりすぎるって
ん
[音楽]
だ
Nファイヤー
トルネード絶対に負けねえやト
[拍手]
うマチ
子供
おりゃ
[音楽]
おりゃここを抑えたら俺らの勝利だこの
パワーとコントロールで絶対に
勝つぞ
[音楽]
早くなりすぎだろ
お残る1人
は
うや
それドラゴン何
[音楽]
スー
アウト
交代さあみんな最後2点を取れば俺らの
勝ち
だて
あれマリールの反動だ10分経つと効果が
少なって弱くなっちゃうん
だ絶望だ次が最後の打席もう終わりだよ
す君それはだめもう限界
[音楽]
よ怖い認めてやるやお前のことはドラゴン
ゴッドブレ
ナイス
ナイス面白えじゃねえ
か勝ってから言いやがれ最終
王義ファイナ
[音楽]
お
よ試合
終了
おいありがとうなえお前らのおかげで久し
ぶりに野球が楽しめたよそうだなあと色々
と悪かったなそれはお互い様だろ
試合結果モカチーム32点バンカラチーム
33点で両チームの野球
追報調べたところ刃物の持ち込みや物破損
そしてそのグローブ動物虐待様々な
スポーツマンシップに反する行為が認め
られたため両チームとも永久追報どどう
なってん
だちゃちゃちゃちゃチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしく最はチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録